[Musique]
jean-claude vous avez également fait un
reportage sur le problème des oeufs en
bas alors à votre avis ça qu'est ce que
c'est il ya ça c'est un off ça ne
ressemble pas à neuf et pourtant c'est
véritablement un iphone et bien vous
avez vous goûté ou verrait bien c'est un
oeuf dur avec du jaune avec du blanc on
n'arrête pas le progrès c'est
effectivement ce qu'on fabrique
désormais en france dans une usine
d'alès et je vous propose de vous rendre
dans cette usine pour faire d eux en
barre il faut des parts d eux des vrais
et de préférence des frais la première
opération consiste à trier ses oeufs
puis elle est lavée puis à les casser
ensuite il fasse sur une machine très
perfectionnés qui permet de garder les
jaunes dans une coupelle tandis que le
blanc c'est cool dans un autre bac
de leur côté les coquilles vont être
récupérés broyé elles sont vendues à des
fabricants de dentifrice est juste
retour des choses
elle entre également dans la composition
des aliments pour volailles
c'est sur cette deuxième machine tout
aussi perfectionné que les bardes of
vont être boulet grâce à un jeu de
cylindres leblanc va d'abord être
coagulé puis le jaune va être cool et au
milieu après vingt minutes de cuisson
l'oeuf dur et prêts à être consommés et
surtout il est prêt à être débité en
belle rondelle normalisée
voici la naissance de l'enfant barre le
résultat est assez appétissant quoique
peut-être un peu déconcertant en une
journée
cent dix mille offres peuvent ainsi être
transformée en 15000 barre jaune et
blanche qui sont exportés pour
l'essentiel vers les pays du
moyen-orient
naturellement pour le dépositaire
libanais de ce brevet danois fabriqué en
exclusivité en france à alès l'intérêt
de l'enfant barre n'est pas purement
esthétique représente un double avantage
pour la grande collectivité la grande
désolation un avantage technique un
avantage économique
l'avantagé technique vous voyez par
exemple alain foulon bien qu'à de couper
vous avez tant six rondelles ces
temps-ci wendel lui dans l' avantage de
supprimer le temps et les frais de
cuisson et supprime la corvée dans les
calages et en même temps l'appel en neuf
cassé ou mal cuite dans chacune de ses
bords il ya l'équivalent de 7 mai selon
le fabricant un restaurateur qui
voudraient obtenir le même nombre de
rondes elles devraient utiliser lui 12e
ordinaire compte tenu de la perte due à
la forme classique d eux pour chaque bar
acheté 7 francs le restaurateur ferait
donc avec le flot une économie de
l'ordre de 4 francs quant aux
consommateurs ils n'auraient rien à
craindre de l'oeuf en bar surgelés
celui-ci ne supplie pour l'instant aucun
traitement chimique et pour conserver sa
blancheur aux blancs d'oeuf
il est permis d'ajouter un peu d'acide
citrique un additif inoffensif mais
malgré tout un additif
enfin dans l'immédiat il n'est pas
question de vendre les oeufs en bar dans
les supermarchés ne consommeront quand
même mais sans le savoir ou restaurants
ou peut-être à la cantine
[Musique]